The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BOGDAN FEDELES: Hi, and welcome
to 5.07 Biochemistry Online,
the biochemistry course
on MIT OpenCourseWare.
I'm Dr. Bogdan Fedeles.
Let's metabolize some problems.
Now today we're going to
do a really nice problem.
This is Problem 1
in Problem Set 2.
Now, this is a problem
about elucidating
the primary structure
of a protein.
Problems like this one
that we're about to discuss
are a lot of fun because they're
really biochemistry puzzles.
We're given a number of
pieces of data or clues,
if you want, and then
we'd have to use,
not only our biochemical
sense, but also
deduction and elimination
process in order
to come up with a final answer.
Well, in practice, elucidating
the primary structure
of a protein is now a
largely automated process
and utilizes high resolution
mass spectrometry.
Some of the traditional
chemical methods
that we're discussing here
are still occasionally useful.
But most importantly, the
logical step-wise process
through which we analyze
and use each piece of data
to construct a
big picture result
is really representative of
the process by which we make
discoveries in biochemistry.
Before we begin, let me just
say that this problem assumes
familiarity with the structures
and abbreviations of the 20
natural amino acids.
Feel free to pause
this video and review
the relevant chapters in the
book and the lecture notes
before continuing.
One important tool that
we have for elucidating
the primary structure of
proteins is proteases.
Proteases are enzymes that can
hydrolyze the peptide bonds
of a polypeptide chain.
Now, proteases that can
cleave in the middle
of a polypeptide chain are
also called endopeptidases.
Now you notice a
lot of these names
that end in "ase" denote
enzymes, and peptidase
means an enzyme that
acts on a peptide.
It's the enzyme that
hydrolyzes the peptide bond.
Endo, in this case,
refers to the fact
that it acts in the middle
of a polypeptide chain.
Now, we're going to be learning
in this problem about trypsin
and chymotrypsin.
These are proteases that
cleave in the middle
of a polypeptide chain.
They are endopeptidases.
One important
feature of proteases
is that they are specific.
They don't just cut any which
one peptide bond, but rather
they recognize a specific
sequence of amino acids.
In the case of
trypsin, for example,
we are told that it cleaves
adjacent to positively
charged amino acid.
As you know, positively
charged amino acids
would be lysine or arginine.
So trypsin will
always be cutting
after arginine or lysine.
Let's take a look.
Now, here is a polypeptide
chain with amino acid residues,
R1, R2, R3, R4.
Now, let's look at
this peptide bond
right here in the
middle of the chain.
Now let's say in
order for trypsin
to cut, to hydrolyze
this peptide bond,
it means that R2, the amino
acid residue adjacent to it,
should be a positively
charged one.
So if R2 is lysine or
arginine, then this bond
here becomes a good
substrate for trypsin.
And what it's going to do, it's
going to use a water molecule--
it's going to put here trypsin--
and it's going to
hydrolyze forming
a carboxyl end and an amine
end of this peptide bond.
So we're getting this
is a carboxyl end
and this is the amine end of
that original peptide bond.
So what I want
you to remember is
that if we're having a
reaction with trypsin
on a polypeptide chain, then
the carboxy end of the peptide
that results, which is
this particular amino acid,
is going to be one of
either lysine or arginine.
So in other words
in a trypsin digest,
all the smaller
peptides that we obtain
are going to end in arginine
or lysine except, of course,
the very end of the
chain, which might
have a different amino
acid at its carboxyl end.
Now, this consideration we've
just made about the trypsin
digest, in fact, answers
part 1 of the problem, which
is asking what is common about
all these peptides generated
by a trypsin digest.
And as we've just explained,
all these peptides
should be ending with a
positively charged amino acid
such as lysine or arginine.
This problem also mentions
another protease chymotrypsin,
which is a protease that
has a different specificity
from trypsin.
It actually cleaves
after amino acids
that are either very hydrophobic
and large or aromatic.
So let's write that
down and remember.
So if we were to do a
digest with chymotrypsin,
then our R2, the residue that's
recognized by the protease,
is going to have to be either
aromatic, so phenylalanine,
tyrosine, or tryptophan,
or something that's
large and hydrophobic such
as leucine, isoleucine,
or even valine sometimes.
Put this in parentheses.
So if any of these residues
are at this position,
R2, then this
protease, chymotrypsin,
is going to generate
two peptides.
And once again, the resulting
peptide, R2 at the carboxy end
is going to be one
of these amino acids.
That's going to be the signature
of a chymotrypsin digest.
Now, keeping these
things in mind,
we're ready to tackle
the rest of the problem.
Question 2 asks about the use
of DTT, or dithiothreitol.
Now, DTT is a commonly
used reducing agent,
which can reduce disulfide
bridges in proteins.
There are many reasons
why we want to use DTT.
For example, when proteins
form disulfide bridges,
you may shield
certain amino acids
from being accessible
by proteases,
and therefore, they're
not going to be cleaved
and we'll get a
mixture of peptides.
So it makes our analysis and
our results very difficult.
Now, disulfide bridges can
also hold two peptides together
that have no other covalent
attachment between them.
So in that case,
we get one fragment
instead of two fragments, and
once again, it complicates
our analysis of the protein.
But more importantly,
because we're typically
purifying proteins in the
air, in an oxygen atmosphere,
proteins can acquire disulfide
bonds, which weren't there
in the beginning.
So in that case, we can
get very unusual results,
unreproducible and artefactual.
That's why using DTT can prevent
formation of spurious disulfide
bridges.
And finally, DTT is
also useful to tell
if there were any disulfide
bridges in the protein
to begin with.
Because if we're
looking at the analysis
before and after using DTT, we
can tell if the results change,
and that will tell us whether
disulfide bridges were there
to begin with.
Now, let's take a look
at the DTT chemistry.
Here we have a disulfide
bond or bridge in a protein,
and we're going to
treat this with DTT,
which looks like this.
This is DTT or dithiothreitol.
Now, if we substitute the
SH groups with OH's, you
notice we're going to have
four OH's and four carbons.
That's just an alcohol
derived from a sugar, which
is called threose That's why
the threitol part of the name.
All right.
So when we do this
chemical reaction,
this disulfide bridge is going
to transfer between the two
sulfur atoms of DTT.
They're going to form a
intramolecular sulfide bond.
So our cysteines are
going to get reduced,
and from DTT, we're going to
get this intramolecular sulfide.
And because entropical
considerations,
make the formation
of the six-member
ring very, very easy, then
this equilibrium will typically
shift to the right.
Of course, we're also using
vast quantities of DTT
to make sure that the entire
protein becomes reduced,
and then our agent is going
to pick up this [INAUDIBLE]
off the bond.
This sums up the question
2 of the problem.
Next, we're going to
look at distinguishing
between a couple of
different peptides
that we generate during
our analysis of our mystery
protein.
So we're told that we're
isolating by HPLC peptides
of the following composition.
One has tryptophan,
phenylalanine,
valine, aspartate,
lysine, cysteine.
That's peptide one.
Another one has phenylalanine,
serine, cysteine,
and an unknown amino acid.
Finally, the third one
has alanine and lysine.
All right.
Now, obviously, these peptides
have different compositions,
so if you could just put them
through mass spectrometry,
we're going to get
different masses,
so we can tell very
quickly which one is which.
But if we don't have
mass spec available,
we can also tell them apart
only using UV-Vis spectroscopy.
So all you need to remember
is that an amino acid
like tryptophan
that we have here,
W, has a very strong absorption
in the 280 to 300 nanometers.
Whereas, amino acids
like phenylalanine,
present here or here, they
absorb only around 260
nanometers.
Most of the other amino acids
don't absorb in this range
at all.
So if we were to plot the UV-Vis
spectra of these peptides,
this is going to
be our absorption,
and this is going to be lambda
in nanometers, the wavelength.
So let's look in the
range from 200 to 400.
300 is about here.
250 is about here.
And let's label these.
Let's say this peptide is
red, this peptide is blue,
and this one is green.
All right.
So now the red
peptide, as I told you,
contains both tryptophan
and phenylalanine,
so it's going to
absorb both around 260
and both around 280 to 300.
So it's going to have a
pretty big hump in this area
from 250 to 300.
Now, the blue peptide
only has phenylalanine,
so above 280 or so, nanometer
is going to drop off.
So it's going to
look more like this,
whereas, the green one, well,
it has neither phenylalanine
or tryptophan, so
below 240 or so,
it's going to have no
UV absorption at all.
So it's going to
drop off right here.
So basically, if
we're just looking,
say, around 260 nanometers,
we should see a stronger peak
from the red peptide and a
weaker peak from the blue one.
But if we're going
to look around 300,
we should only see
the red peptide.
So by just using the
UV-Vis absorption,
we can tell these
three peptides apart.
Now we're ready to figure out
the structure of our mystery
protein.
This is exactly what the last
part of the problem is asking.
So we're going to take each
one of the clues provided--
A, B, C, and D--
and analyze and see
what information we can
derive from each one of them.
The first piece of
information that we're given
is the result of
a total hydrolysis
of our peptide
with six molar HCl.
So we're told we get
the following amino acid
composition.
We get two phenylalanines, one
methionine, alanine, valine,
two lysines, one serine, two
cysteine, and one aspartate.
Now, recall this is not
a comprehensive list
because the hydrolysis
and six smaller HCl
may destroy some
of the amino acids.
And specifically, we
know for sure something
like tryptophan,
threonine, and tyrosine.
They're going to be
destroyed, and we're not
going to see them here.
So these amino acids may still
be present in our protein,
but we're not going to be able
to see them in this situation.
Now, let's analyze
these amino acids
and see what we can
derive from this.
So first of all,
we have cysteines.
So two cysteines,
it means our protein
can form disulfide bridges.
So from the get
go, two cysteine,
it means we can form an
internal disulfide bridge
or our protein contains a
disulfide bridge between two
otherwise unconnected peptides.
So here are some possibilities.
For example, our
peptide is one chain,
and our cysteines are
not actually connected
by a disulfide bridge.
Another possibility is we
do have a disulfide bridge
between them, like that.
Or yet another possibility is
that we have two pieces, two
polypeptide chains, and
the disulfide bridge
is the only thing that's
holding them together.
Now, in each one of
these cases, obviously,
these polypeptide
chains are oriented.
So in one end, they're going
to have the amine group.
Let me draw it here, NH3.
Here we're going to have
two, and the other end
is going to be the
carboxyl group, COO minus.
And once again, in
this case, we're
going to have two of them.
All right.
Now, how can we narrow down from
these couple of possibilities?
Well, the fact that we're
getting two lysines here
is a very important clue.
Now remember, we're told that
our peptide, this mystery
protein, it actually comes as
a result of a trypsin digest.
And if you recall our
discussion earlier,
we said that upon
trypsin digest,
all the smaller peptides
that were obtained
will end in lysine
or an arginine.
The fact that we have
two lysines here,
it means both of
them they need to be
at the carboxy ends of peptides.
Because if they were in
the middle of a chain,
the trypsin would have
cut that chain in half.
So two lysines means we've
got to have two carboxy ends.
So therefore, this seems to be
the only possibility in which
we can accommodate two lysines.
Basically, the two carboxy
ends that we see here,
each one has to be a lysine.
This possibility only
has one carboxy end,
so the other lysine
that we have to place
will not be at the
end, so would not
be compatible with
a trypsin digest.
Same applies for this case.
So these possibilities are
not consistent with our data.
So we know already
that our protein must
look like this, two
polypeptide chains,
each one ends with
lysine, and there
must be a disulfide bridge.
The second clue we're given
is that the Edman degradation
of the protein yields valine.
Now, as you know,
Edman degradation
is a chemical reaction by
which we can digest the protein
from the N terminus,
from the amino terminus
of a polypeptide chain.
Now as you recall, we have
established in the first part
that we have two amino
termini in our protein.
So the fact that we only get one
amino acid and that is valine,
it says that the
other amino terminus
might be blocked or
somehow unavailable
for the Edman degradation.
So let's update the
structure of our protein
to take into account
the second clue.
So we said we have two
polypeptide chains.
There's a disulfide
bond in between them.
Now, each one of them
ends with a lysine.
This is a carboxy
end, and now we
know from the Edman degradation
that amino end of one of them
has to be valine.
The other one-- we're going
to put a box like that--
is a blocked end.
So the amino terminus
is not available.
So this is as much as we can
tell from these first two
clues.
We're given the products
of the chymotrypsin
digest of our protein
after it was previously
treated with DTT.
So we know first DTT is going
to cleave the disulfide bond,
and then chymotrypsin,
as we talked previously,
is going to cut after large,
hydrophobic, or aromatic
amino acids.
Now, we're told we're getting
five smaller peptides.
Let's take a look.
Here are the five fragments.
One is tryptophan, valine; one
is cysteine, phenylalanine,
another one is aspartate
lysine, another one
is methionine, alanine,
cysteine, and lysine;
and finally, the last one
has serine, phenylalanine,
and something that's
not an amino acid.
It's going to make
it like a small x.
All right.
Now, from what we know
about chymotrypsin digest,
we should be able to orient
these peptides basically
to tell which amino acid
is at the N terminus
and which amino acid is at the
C terminus of each one of them.
Now the first one.
Well, we know from
the second clue
that valine is at
the N terminus,
so that makes it pretty easy.
Then the sequence has to be V-W.
So valine is the N terminus,
W is the C terminus,
and as we said,
tryptophan is one of the
amino acids recognized
by chymotrypsin, so
it's going to end up
at the carboxy terminus.
C-F, that has to go C
and F, phenylalanine,
another chymotrypsin
amino acid that's
left of this carboxy terminus.
D-K. Now, neither
of these amino acids
is recognized by chymotrypsin,
but we remember from clue one
that D-K must be the
carboxy terminus.
So the sequence can only be D-K.
Now, here M, A, C,
and K, none of these
is actually on our recognition
list for chymotrypsin,
but once again, we know that
K must be in the carboxy end.
So for now we're
going to have M, A,
and C in a particular order,
which we cannot establish just
yet and K at the carboxy end.
And finally, we
do an S, F and x.
Well, x is not
even an amino acid,
and F is an amino acid that's
left of the carboxy terminus
by chymotrypsin, so it's
probably x, S, and F. Now,
what about x?
We're told that x is not an
amino acid and is hydrophobic
and it has a molecular
weight of 256 Daltons.
All right.
So in order to
figure out what x is,
we have to read back the
beginning of the problem, which
tells us that we're looking
at a protein that's associated
with a plasma membrane.
And one way for proteins
to associate with a plasma
membrane is to be modified,
to incorporate a fatty acid,
such as palmitate.
So perhaps x, which is blocking
the N terminus of this peptide
is a fatty acid.
Now, the general
formula for fatty acids
is something like this,
CH3 CH2 repeated, say,
n times, and then COOH.
So let's see what would
be the fatty acid that
has the molecular
weight 256 Daltons?
Well, the mass of a
methyl group is 15.
The mass of this carboxylate
is 45, so we have about 60
plus 14n equals 256
or 14n equals 196.
Therefore, n is 14.
So the fatty acid that
would fit these criteria--
it's hydrophobic, it
has a mass of 256--
will be CH3, CH2 14 times
COOH, or the fatty acid
was 16 carbons.
This is palmitic acid.
Now, the answer that
we got, palmitic acid,
was anticipated in the
text of the problem
because it gave us an example
one way to associate proteins
to the plasma
membrane is to form
a covalent linkage with a
fatty acid such as palmitate.
But how does a protein
associate with a plasma
membrane when it has a palmitic
acid residue as part of it?
Well, let's take a
look at a diagram.
Here we have a representation
of the plasma membrane,
where we have the phospholipids
like the hydrophilic head
pointing inside and outside the
cell and the hydrophobic tails
of the fatty acids
lined up to each other.
Now, imagine we have
a protein that's
modified to contain one
of these fatty acids.
Then this fatty acid can
just insert right next
to the phospholipids
of the plasma membrane.
And that way it tethers
the protein right
at the plasma membrane.
The final clue that we're
given in order to figure out
the structure of
our mystery protein
is the digest with an
inorganic agent this time.
It's called cyanogen bromide.
Cyanogen bromide reacts quite
specifically with methionines,
and it cleaves the peptide
bond after methionine
leaving behind an
unnatural amino acid called
a homoserine lactone.
Now, let's take a
look at what happens
when we treat our protein
with cyanogen bromide.
So we're told we're getting
the following peptides, A, K
and W, F, V, D, K, C and F, S,
C, and an unnatural amino acid.
As I just explained to you, the
unnatural amino acid probably
is this homoserine lactone.
So it's most likely,
instead of this amino acid
in the actual sequence,
we had a methionine.
So we know these four residues--
F, S, C, and M--
go together.
All right.
Now, we can start putting
together the clues
from part 3 and 4 and try to
figure out the final structure
of our protein.
So the peptide A, K, we know
has to have K at the C terminus.
Now, from part 3, we
found out that there
was a peptide that
contained M, A, C, and K,
after the chymotrypsin digest.
So now we know K has
to be the carboxy end
and A has to be right
before K, so in order
to get an A-K
peptide, then A has
to be right after
methionine because that's
where cyanogen bromide is going
to cleave the peptide bond.
So the only sequence
that we can have here is
going to be C followed
by M followed by A
followed by K. So when we
treat the cyanogen bromide,
we're going to be cleaving
this bond between M and A,
generating M as a
homoserine lactone.
Now, we also know that M has
to be in this small peptide,
and we know it has to
be C, M as a sequence.
So therefore, S and F have
to be on the amino terminus
of this peptide.
And we also have a
clue from part 3, which
said that S, F, and this
non amino acid moiety
were in the same peptide.
So from here we said that,
well, the sequence there, it's
probably x modifying the amino
S and then F with a carboxy end.
So putting these
three things together,
we can come up with a sequence
for this strand, which
is going to be x, S,
F, then C, M and then A
and K. So this is probably
one of the peptide chains
in our mystery protein.
Then, of course,
the other is going
to be composed of
these amino acids.
Now, we already know something
about the sequence of these.
For example, we know V
goes before W. We also
know D goes before K, and also
know C goes before F. Now, we
know this has to be the carboxy
end of the peptide chain.
Let's write it here, COO minus.
And V has to be the amino end.
So then C-F, there's no other
way, has to be in the middle.
So the only possible
sequence for our second chain
is going to be V,
W, C, F, D, and K.
Now that we've established
the exact sequence
of each one of these
peptide chains,
then we can put together
the final structure
of our mystery protein.
So I'm going to transcribe these
here, the first chain V, W, C,
F, D, and K. And we know
the cysteine is going
to have our disulfide bridge
to the other cysteine, which
goes C, M, A, K, and
then F, and then S.
And now we know the N
terminus of this peptide,
we're going to have our fatty
acid residue CH2 14 times CH3.
So let's just mark, once
again, the carboxy ends here
and the amino end here.
So this is the final
answer for our problem
and the structure of
our mystery peptide.
Well, that's it
for this problem.
I hope you enjoyed this
little protein mystery hunt.
Now, remember that the
strategy that we used here
in which we logically string
together pieces of data
to build a big picture, it's
really the same strategy
that has been used and is
being used right now to advance
our knowledge about living
systems and their underlying
biochemistry.